América Latina se enfrenta a un 2023 con
dificultades en materia de empleo un
informe publicado por la organización
Internacional del trabajo Indicó que en
este 2023 el crecimiento laboral se
estancará luego del impulso tomado en la
post pandemia
la entidad estima que latinoamérica
solamente crecerá un
0,9%, mientras que en América del Norte
no habrá incremento e incluso el
desempleo reputará en Franz 24 el
analista Daniel lacalle explicó los
motivos de estas previsiones por lo que
significa fundamentalmente es que
América Latina no solamente se está
empobreciendo sino que está perdiendo
muchos pasos con respecto al crecimiento
global la oit remarcó que uno de los
grandes inconvenientes afrontar es el
constante aumento del empleo informal la
desaceleración obligaría a muchos a
aceptar condiciones laborales más
precarias la organización subrayó que la
calidad de los puestos de trabajo sigue
siendo una preocupación fundamental
porque deja a muchas personas
imposibilitadas de acceder a mecanismo
de protección social en América Latina
donde la informalidad supera el 53%, el
deterioro económico general potenciar
estos déficits entre otros efectos
negativos el informe también expuso una
disparidad entre hombres y mujeres en el
último año ciento de la población activa
masculina estuvo ocupada mientras que la
femenina apenas rondó el 46% claramente
Hay un problema de
constantes trabas a la inversión y
además Hay un problema cultural de
la idea generalizada de que las tareas
domésticas tienen que recaer en las
mujeres el nuevo año le plantearé
engorrosos desafíos a una región que ya
ha padecido en 2022 con desaceleraciones
y alta inflación